i don't think you can motivate the
unmotivated i i don't think you could
motivate people people either are
motivated or unmotivated i think you can
inspire people um
and uh and you know you can motivate
people with
sticks and carrots you know offer them
bounty or threatened punishment
and you'll get behavior that you want is
there loyalty is there love absolutely
not
um usually when people are unmotivated
it's not necessarily them it might be
the situation they're in
maybe they don't belong in the culture
maybe they feel unseen or unheard
maybe they're scared maybe they're
unprepared so we we have to
you know when somebody's unmotivated
let's not label them as unmotivated
first
what are the 20 other things that it
could also be let's start there
now are there some people in the world
who are maybe unmotivated absolutely
you hired them which means you bear some
responsibility
if it's if it's time to transition them
to help them find another place where
they're going to be a better fit
we can't yell at them and call them
stupid unmotivated and push them out the
door
we have to bear some of the
responsibility we hired them and if we
made a mistake and hired somebody who's
a bad cultural fit
then we have to take care of them and
help them transition to somewhere where
they're going to be
a better fit i think that you know if we
only focus on
motivating people and that's a factor
then
um you're only going to get very finite
thinking an excessive amount of
motivating things like hit this number
get this bonus
you'll get a motivated employee pool
that doesn't care about each other might
stab each other in the back
and eventually we'll take a better job
somewhere else we have to inspire people
we have to give them that sense of cause
and vision that their work is worth more
we have to make them feel like they
matter and feel like they're seen and
heard and understood
and what ends up happening is those
people are not only more vote motivated
and inspired
but if they're offered a better higher
paying job somewhere else they turn it
down
because it's not just about the bonuses
and the money it's because they would
rather be here with these wonderful
people
you